aquí tenemos dos copias de seis
polígonos distintos y lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es ver cuáles de
estos polígonos permanecen invariantes
al hacer una rotación de 180 grados en
el centro del polígono déjame hacer un
par de ejemplos voy a empezar con el
cuadrado si tomo el cuadrado y lo roto
180 grados entonces seguramente va a
permanecer invariante vamos a ver eso
ahí lo rotamos 90 grados y ahí lo
rotamos 180 grados creo que queda un
poquito chueco 180 grados y en efecto el
cuadrado queda igualito permanece
invariable después de la rotación de 180
grados vamos a ver qué sucede ahora con
esta figura de acá
esta figura es un trapecio vamos a ver
qué pasa cuando lo rotamos voy a tomar
el trapecio para rotarlo y déjame
girarlo ahí van 90 grados haya roto 90
grados vamos a rotarlo un poco más ahí
son 180 grados y si te das cuenta ahora
quedo distinto al principio la base era
más larga que la que el segmento de
arriba y aquí la base quedó más corta
que el segmento de arriba entonces el
trapecio no permanece invariable si se
obtiene una figura distinta muy bien
entonces ahora te invito a intentar los
otros cuatro por tu cuenta
déjame seguir con este aquí tenemos una
como estrella no sé como estrella ninja
esta estrella ninja parece ser que si va
a permanecer fija y una forma de
pensarlo es la siguiente si tomamos el
centro de la figura que está más o menos
aquí entonces al reflejar este punto al
rotar este punto 180 grados primero con
90 llegamos aquí y luego con otros 90
llegamos acá de modo similar este va
para acá este
y este va para acá así que parece ser
que la estrella va a permanecer
invariante vamos a ver qué sucede
la rotamos 90 grados ahí van 90 grados y
ahora vamos a rotar la otros 90 grados y
si en efecto la estrella permaneció
invariable vamos ahora a este de acá
este es un paralelogramo nos indica que
este lado es paralelo a este y éste a
este si pensamos que por aquí está el
centro entonces este al rotar 180 grados
va a llegar a ver de aquí al centro es
esta distancia y luego del centro a la
rotación va a ser una distancia igual
así que este parece que va a caer acá y
de modo similar de aquí para acá es la
misma distancia que de aquí para acá
este es el centro entonces parece ser
que éste tras rotar 180 grados va a caer
acá entonces éste va a este este va a
este y viceversa así que parece ser que
va a permanecer invariante
déjame ver rotamos y frote muy rápido
ahí son 90 grados 90 grados y si roto
otros 90 llegó aquí y en efecto queda la
misma figura no hay que hacerle caso
hacia donde apuntan las flechas recuerda
que eso solo indica que los lados son
paralelos si ignoramos eso queda
exactamente lo mismo y entonces
permanece invariable vamos ahora a este
triángulo de acá el centro de este
triángulo va a estar aproximadamente por
aquí y qué sucede cuando rotamos 180
grados y nos vamos de este punto a este
punto y luego recorremos una distancia
igual caemos más o menos por acá y eso
ya cae fuera de modo similar este va a
caer como por acá que cae fuera y este
por acá entonces al parecer no va a
resultar la misma figura vamos a
verificarlo entonces déjame rotar ahí
son 90 grados 90 grados y otros 90 son
180 y en efecto queda una figura
distinta aquí el triángulo está digamos
apuntando para allá y aquí está
apuntando para allá entonces no
permaneció invariable y finalmente aquí
tenemos este papalote vamos a ver qué le
sucede parece ser que no va a quedar
igual verdad sino que va a quedar una
copia boca abajo déjame rotar 90 grados
ok y ahora otros 90 grados y en efecto
queda diferente aquí apunta hacia abajo
y aquí apunta hacia arriba si éste
papalote además fuera simétrico
simétrico por una línea horizontal esto
sería una historia totalmente distinta y
a lo mejor sería un poco más interesante
pero así así como está al rotar 180
grados éste papalote queda distinto